[Music]
the value of communication in today's
world is only increasing the way we do
it is changing be it virtual with
webinars or on our cell phones but
communication is absolutely critical
things are moving faster there's more
information we have to process we are
multitasking it rates and never seen
before
the ability to communicate clearly
confidently and in a compelling way is
absolutely critical to business success
when it comes to virtual communication
especially if you're on video there's
some things that you can do to really
help first make sure you've got good
technology make sure there's a
microphone that picks up your voice make
sure you have a camera that displays
things well make sure that the
environment you're speaking in is ready
for you so that means make sure there's
nothing distracting behind you make sure
you have lighting so that you look
decent
most of the lighting we have in our
workstations is not flattering when
you're on camera you want elevated
lighting that's shining on you and when
it comes to actually communicating to
people on the other end of your video
conference look directly at the camera
the camera is as if you're looking in
their eyes many of us when we interact
online we look down because our notes
are here our keyboards here it's as if
we're talking to somebody's shoes if you
are having a face-to-face interaction so
it's really critical when you're online
as you look at the camera and you focus
there
now you might be asking how do I know
what to say I need my notes tape some
notes behind your camera I actually am I
set up at home I went to the hardware
store I spent 10 dollars for an outdoor
light that a mechanic uses to look under
the hood I mount that light behind my
camera I have an old music stand and on
that music stand
I have propped up my notes so I'm lit
well and I can see my notes while
looking at the camera
it makes a world of difference in coming
across as somebody who's engaged and
connected
people need to be prepared for all
different types of communication
situations be at a meeting be at a
presentation be it being an audience
member in in a presentation I encourage
everybody to go into any communication
event thinking about what are the key
questions I have that I want answers to
second what are the key points or themes
that I want to get across and with those
themes come up with some examples to
support them or to reinforce what you're
trying to get across if you go into any
communication situation with those
questions in mind and those themes in
your back pocket you will be able to
contribute more and ultimately take away
more from those situations
[Music]
you